j'aimerais comprendre le nombre
d'adhérents à votre association et son
budget disons en 2020 une année avant
avant que vous déposiez un projet auprès
du cipdr pour mesurer l'écart entre
enfin l'écart ou la conformité entre
votre budget 2020 et puis la demande de
subvention 2021 et ma deuxième question
vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure monsieur
le Président que vous avez dû déposer un
grand nombre de CERFA et j'ai pas
compris pourquoi il a fallu déposer et
donc vous saviez plus de quel c'était
pourquoi a-t-il fallu déposer un grand
nombre de CERFA la demande de qui
très bien alors pour répondre à votre
première question le nombre de
d'adhérents a beaucoup fluctué vous
l'avez compris maintenant à cause
notamment de ces de ces conflits
internes lors de la demande de
subvention nous avions fortement réduit
l'effectif en ayant que des personnes
voilà vraiment
sûr donc on était on était cinq à
l'association le budget était annuel
habituel était de 50000 euros environ
et il est sûr que le fond Marianne est
au-delà du fond Marianne ce projet elle
est modifiée substantiellement notre
budget parce qu'on passait vraiment dans
une
on sait vraiment une nouvelle une
nouvelle activité